et on dirait que dans ce gîte et
virginie martin politologue professeur
chercheuse à quel jeu business school à
marseille bonjour virginie marc
st-martin merci de répondre à nos
questions sur rt france quel bilan est
ce que vous tirez des dix premiers jours
de jean castex à matignon eh bien
écoutez d'abord il ya quand même
beaucoup de déplacements beaucoup
d'agitation on va dire mais toujours pas
de lignes directrices toujours pas de
discours de politique générale toujours
pas de cadre et ça c'est un peu voilà
c'est un peu troublant on va dire ça
c'est le déjà le premier point puisque
vous le savez comme moi emmanuel macron
veut garder la priorité du discours
général notamment le 14 juillet donc
c'est un peu rare et troublant quand le
premier ministre ne puisse pas
véritablement définir sa ligne de
conduite c'est quand même le premier
poids troublant est ce que ça veut dire
que c'est un exécutant écoutait est ce
que c'était où est ce que c'est en super
communicants qui doit absolument donner
l'impression qu'ils modèlent macron
atterrir un peu sur terre on parle
beaucoup souvent inutilement de l'accent
jean castex
mais est-ce que l'accent fait le terroir
peut-être pas mais dont nos inconscients
ils impriment quelque chose du terroir
donc finalement est-ce qu'il est super
intendant super communication non je ne
sais pas fin de non recevoir en la vue
sur le sujet de thé aux combes fin de
non-recevoir unanime des partenaires
sociaux sur les dossiers de la retraite
quel type de relation à l'avenir entre
les syndicats et matignon selon vous ac
c'est compliqué parce que si vous voulez
si on est si on prend un peu de recul et
qu'on se dit que pour l'instant le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron n'aura été
symbolisé que par beaucoup de tension
beaucoup d'échecs les gilet jaune
évidemment qu vite il n'y est pas pour
grand chose mais la mauvaise gestion du
coup vide
oui on se dit qu'il faut absolument
qu'il maniait macron est une réforme à
son actif
à terre une réforme très clairs et
visibles qui sera symbole de son
quinquennat
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il surfe beaucoup
à cette réforme des retraites même si
comme le disent les partenaires sociaux
ça tombe ou très mauvais moment dans
votre sujet il n'y a pas d'âge
le patron omri que des cadres du
syndicat des carmes et lui aussi est
très opposé depuis très longtemps cette
réforme par points jean castex en guyane
aujourd'hui opération communication ou
véritables scènes d'action là de toute
façon il n'y a pas le choix mais au delà
de la guyane puisque c'est la question
du coc vide qui est quand même très
sérieuse
il y à aussi quid du territoire de la
métropole
parce que là nous avons un problème on
voit bien que ça revient un petit peu
cette histoire de qu'ovide s qu'oliver
véran pourra dire comme base b agnès
buzyn à l'époque on ne savait pas
exactement ne savait pas trop on était
danflous là on n'est plus dans le flou
il ya aujourd'hui une quinzaine de
médecins qui alerte en dix ans les
gestes barrière ne sont absolument pas
respectée donc quid de la métropole un
en guyane c'est déjà explosif mais ici
ça va aussi leur devenir
et puis autre sujet explosif la plus
éthique
évidemment la question de dharmanand
grossi évidemment par la question de
dupond moretti sur ses positions à
l'égard de mitu et de balances ton port
où là on a vraiment un problème éthique
et politique sûrement vous parlez de
gérald darmanin qui s'est déplacé à
dijon 1 avec jean castex pour soutenir
les forces de l'ordre on a vu jean
castex a également comme vous l'avez dit
beaucoup communiquer cette semaine mais
en terme de communication justement
quand il annonce par exemple que le
gouvernement la semaine dernière sera
formé avant lundi selon ses mots et que
l'elysée annonce finalement lundi matin
beaucoup y ont vu un recadrage qu'est-ce
que ça traduit alors qu emmanuel macron
vous l'avez dit va s'exprimer mardi
oui il ya beaucoup de recadrage et on
voit bien qu'il est je ne voudrais pas
dire ça mais presque à la botte de
l'elysée au sens strict du terme
alors évidemment
dans cet exécutif bicéphale à la
française c'est souvent comme cela que
ça se passe
mais là c'est encore plus flagrant
rappelez vous aussi on l'a commenté la
semaine dernière l'ensemble me
semble-t-il
il ya aussi le chef de cabinet le
directeur de cabinet des chefs de
cabinet ici ou là dans plusieurs
ministères qui sont finalement des
obligés d manueel macro et même des très
proches des bagnoles macron donc on voit
finalement la technocratie macro nien
être un peu partout et placer ses pieds
c'est pouillon partout merci virginie
martin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes politologue
enseignante-chercheuse as catch business
school à marseille avec plaisir